la sensation du dernier défilé couture
chanel c'est elle victoria charity elle
déambule avec grâce pour ce divin finale
et dans ce jardin à l'italienne belle à
se damner des yeux à la vire na li zhi
et la bouche bien fait
la mariée était en costume de bain ce
tracé de 400 heures de cristaux rodez
parler minutieusement des ateliers
lesage karl lagerfeld lui avait confié
s'être réveillé au milieu d'une nuit et
à voir d'un très dessiné ce bijou pour
elle et rien que pour elle petit rencard
avec victor la place des victoires
suivront l'a2 près pour un essayage chez
isabel marant
est-ce que les couleurs sont victoria ça
va
des bagues
[Musique]
à bercy entend la caissière qui colle et
là
parfait et on va mettre celle là
[Musique]
une antique
aussi parfaite
et ringo cartes emv aux états unis il
faut commencer par les utilisent
[Musique]
c'est là et après je pense que ça va pas
être ce pantalon à quelle force parce
que oui le portail de combat voire cinq
ans avec huawei elle va faire sur celui
là pourtant fait normalement il a
m
demandez à valentino crédit avec windows
dans les pods jamais bien mal à ma main
et pour préparer les 47 mannequin de la
cabine 60 habilleuse dont cinq rien que
pour elle
de host of the show boat et ben foster
chaud et françois chalot touche à tout
[Musique]